it's time for the launching horoscope
the television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus cope mister william bradford
huie and mr. robert colborne an editor
of Business Week magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
mr. Paul C aebersold director of the
isotopes division of the United States
Atomic Energy Commission mr. Ava soul
you of course had just arrived from that
fabulous place Oak Ridge Tennessee and I
believe you've spent most of your adult
life in atomic energy so I'm sure that
you're equipped to give our viewers and
up-to-the-minute report on developments
in the atomic energy field first of all
sir can you illustrate simply for us how
extensive the atomic energy program is
today the atomic energy program is big
business that's about as large as any of
the largest corporations the United
States at the present time when our
expansion program is complete as big as
usq not quite as big as US Steel but it
will be about eight billion dollars at
the end of this expansion period which
means about two hundred dollars or more
per family invested in other words every
American family now has two hundred
hours invested in atomic energy that's a
total of about eight billion dollars
that's why everybody how many people are
working for it now about a hundred
thousand people work on the program and
operations and construction as lot of
people directly working for the
government these people don't work for
the government the only about 6,000
people work for the Atomic Energy
Commission itself so that most of the
work is actually done by private
industrial contractors well is
comic energy a government monopoly at
the moment well in some senses it is
because legally certain functions are
can only be done by under government
supervision but the Commission is
exploring ways of having certain phases
of atomic energy program taken over by
private in-n-out what are your specific
responsibilities in the programs well
I'm concerned with peacetime
applications or byproducts of atomic
energy called radioisotopes these are
radioactive atoms that we make it
oakridge with around explain that a
little more the truth or so well of
course that's a technical term but I
think it'll become as popular someday as
radio television all of the terms of it
were technical at one can you show our
viewers just while can you illustrate
just what an isotope yes they're
radioactive atoms I have a couple of
bottles here this is the bottle of
radioactive iodine is the bottle of
radioactive phosphorus and we can make
radioactive forms of all the elements
around us here varieties that bottle of
iodine is just like any other iodine
except some of the atoms in it they give
off radiation yes by radioactive I mean
that they give off raised atomic rays
that and while I check those with an
instrument like those from radium and
and x-ray machine so on these give off
similar radiations all right now what
can you do with that bottle of iodine
that you couldn't do with a bottle of
ordinary iodine well he's uh these
radioactive iodine atoms can be traced
because of the atomic rays that they
give off one can follow them with atomic
instruments you can follow extremely
small quantities of radioactive atoms
you can follow as small as a B&B
announced when I was late I mean what
does that mean in red and medical
research for instance well they're
called tracer atoms because we can put
these into a biological system i'm in a
plant or an animal or man even and trace
where these atoms go for example if i
swallowed that bottle the iodine would
go to my thyroid just the same as if it
were ordinary either it would behave in
your system just the same chemically and
physically just like iodine and your
body doesn't know the difference except
that it gives off raise you can find out
where it where it is those atoms are
saying look I'm item Adams I'm here in
your thyroid gland and to the scientists
and you can tell where they are and also
if I happen to need some rays in my
thyroid is I'm my
if it were too big that's right there
two years in a treatment there are two
uses for these things one is as tracer
atoms in which you use very very small
amounts to find out where these items
are going the other is to use them as
sources of radiation to to x-ray like
x-rays to treat or to do something in
industry would like take pictures and so
on so that you can use the radiation in
a practical ertl how much use is very
fast there by Stokes now very many
people using them well there are over a
thousand institutions in the United
States that are using isotopes and we've
shipped out about 40,000 shipments all
over the gift would be hospitals and
laboratories hospitals research
laboratories and now several hundred
industrial companies are the industrial
company use it well they again use them
in two ways one for research to find out
mechanisms or how things act what atoms
are doing in all kinds of processes well
how would you say what could you find
out about an engine well you could for
example we you could send us a piston
ring and we could put it in our reactor
at oak ridge and the atomic rays in the
reactor will make this distant radio
active when you put in a motor when the
piston goes up and down you wear off a
little bit of radioactive iron we can
detect that way as little as a hundred
thousandths of an ounce of where from
the piston ring while the motors running
now you couldn't find that much of that
much where if it weren't radioactive you
would take you months to get the same
answer on comparing one lubricating oil
with another or comparing high-speed
operation of a motor with low speed
whereas with a radioactive piston ring
you can get this information a matter of
hours that is I put this piston ring in
run it for an hour so with 1 i'll run it
for an hour so with another oil and from
the amount of the radioactive stuff that
comes through i can tell which i was
wearing it well that's right and you can
do it without ever opening of the motor
and making no tests I mean you don't
have to change the conditions at all
what are you contributing to cancer
research I'm glad you asked that because
we've had a very active program the
Commission not only distributes isotopes
for cancer research at reduced prices
there to about 500 hospitals around the
country but the Commission itself has a
large number of research contracts in
mental biology and medicine several
hundred contracts in universities and
research institutions throughout the
country so the commissioners had a very
active program to help in cancer
research well now what about
agricultural research is are these
isotopes useful in agriculture which are
using all fields of research the matter
of fact agriculture pure science and
medicine and Industry non-agriculture
they're largely used as tracer atoms
that is to find out how a plant utilizes
fertilizer from the soil or how the
plant takes carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and make sugar I'd like to go
back to his cancer thing a bit too
immature so there are people curing
cancer with isotopes well the word cure
isn't very popular in the cancer field
because it's difficult to say that
you've had a complete cure but people
can be alleviated the disease the
symptoms of the disease can be reduced
and so that people can live longer and
live more comfortably that is you can
get radiation to a cancer which isotopes
more easily than you can with x-ray in
some cases we can we have machines that
have been made using radioactive cobalt
for example which gives off a million
volt rays raizle million volts of energy
like very high-powered x-rays that's
right like a very high-powered x-rays so
now it's cheaper what about the security
and secrecy in this field so you have
shipped these isotopes overseas to all
the free world haven't you that's right
in other words our government is not
imposing in a security in this field we
are sharing the peacetime knowledge and
uses of atomic energy with the rest of
the world that's why we're very happy
that in this particular field that
they're there is not any security these
atoms are just like atoms of ordinary
elements except they're radioactive
there are other people in the world now
who make radioisotopes there are
reactors or these atomic ovens as we
call them in many other countries today
when I coming back to the atomic energy
program in general sir where it was the
free world hurt did we suffer from from
atomic espionage well certainly we did
but I'm happy to say that I don't
believe that there any US scientists of
any note that were involved I think that
our own security program was very well
handled and is being well handled today
now you recognize so are you that we
still great need for secrecy as far as
the weapons development weapons
development there's a need for secrecy
but even there there's a philosophy
desirable to overdo secrecy too so that
it restricts your own development does
it can therefore there's a philosophy
that security another phase of security
is security by accomplishment the more
you can accomplish keep ahead of the
other follow do it faster and we can do
more that way by as much information as
we can release it will help our own
science and technology will further are
the two terms of security can contradict
each other to some you have security by
secrecy and you need some of that
particular in weapons and military
applications but if you overdo that
you're restricting your own scientific
projects well now how much is the atomic
energy program going to affect the life
of the average American in our lifetime
well it will not revolutionize our
lifetime because we've already had a
revolution technology in this country in
the last 50 years so that it's hard to
say that atomic energy is going to
revolutionize things but it will be a
it's a powerful new source of energy
there will be a Tomic power for useful
purposes within the next decade
certainly are these reviews doesn't
fuels like cool well not competing but
supplementing I think that they won't
atomic power won't replace the coal or
oil but it will supplement and many
there will be many uses for this power
when are you mentioned that we now have
about eight billion dollars invested in
the atomic energy program now as most of
that waste I mean as most of that in in
weapons or in material that can be used
only for weapons I'm glad you asked that
because actually only about fifteen
percent or something like that of our
expenditures are on a purely military
program in which you
might not get anything back but about
75% of the effort is in making this
atomic explosives fissionable material
we call them with uranium get you
anything by rhenium and plutonium and
those can be used that that material can
be used for useful power and it's stored
going to do that distribution well you
see this doesn't decay rapidly plutonium
and uranium don't decay rapidly and
they're just as good as gold except that
they are source of energy so we're
storing up a future potential source of
energy when I was a final question sir
most Americans have heard it said that
maybe atomic energy was going to be a
device by which we just destroyed all
human life on this planet do you feel
that the program is going to end an
eventual destruction of human life what
do you think that it may be an agency by
which human life is made better for
everyone in the world well I don't think
man was put here to destroy himself and
I think that our stockpile of atomic
weapons is really a great thing for
national security I don't think other
nations will risk war with us we as long
as we keep foremost in the atomic energy
atomic weapon field it's a very great
thing for national security and long run
I think there'd be greater contributions
from the peacetime aspects them from the
military well thank you very much for
being with us this evening sir and this
has been very reassuring the opinions
you've heard our speakers expressed
tonight are entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching cronin scope was mister
william bradford huie and mr. robert
colborne an editor of Business Week
magazine our distinguished guest was mr.
Paul C aebersold director of the
isotopes division of the United States
Atomic Energy Commission